A second key programming
tool is the for loop.
A for loop is a structure used
to execute a set of code
repeatedly.
The for loop statement specifier
is an index over
which the loop is computed.
For example, here I'll execute
a for loop using an
index called i.
The object, i, will start the
loop by taking the first value
in the 1 through 10 vector.
That is, to start,
i will equal 1.
Next, the for loop
will execute.
Then i will take the next value
in this vector, which is
2, and loop will
execute again.
This will continue until i has
taken the last value in the
vector, 10, and the code
executes one last time.
In this set of code, the value
i squared will be appended to
the vector, x, using the
append function.
Here I got an error.
I'll take a closer look.
I can see that x never actually
existed, so there was
no way to append anything onto
the first iteration.
To fix this, I'll just
initialize x as an empty
vector using the concatenate
function, but leaving the
arguments empty.
OK, this runs well.
Look at x.
In each iteration the value
of i squared was appended
to the end of x.
So the first element was created
when i was 1, the
second when i was
2, and so on.
OK, I've done something
pretty cool here.
I've done 10 calculations
using a for loop, and it
wouldn't be hard to
do many more with
the same set of code.
For example, i could easily go
from 1 to 100, rather than
just 1 to 10.
While there are other, better
ways to do this particular
calculation, there are instances
where for loop is
very useful.
All right, one more look
at the stock data.
To calculate the smallest and
largest values for each stock
in the stock data set, I'm going
to start by creating an
object called the.tickers that
is just a list of the unique
stock tickers in the data.
Since for loops can iterate over
any vector, I will write
a for loop to iterate over the
object that I've called
the.tickers.
It's sometimes helpful to also
give a meaningful name to the
index, so I'm going to change
the index i to ticker.
Now I need to create code
for the general case.
For a given ticker, calculate
both the low
and the high value.
I'll start by identifying which
rows are of interest in
the stocks data set.
The vector called look.at is
a Boolean vector indicating
which observations represent
the.ticker
for the given iteration.
Next, I can create two
statements to calculate the
lowest low and highest high
of these observations.
Finally, I need to store
these values somehow.
I can start by initializing two
objects, lows and highs.
Next, I can use an append
command to append a value on
to the end of the vector.
All right, I can run the code
and print the results, but
something's wrong.
While I'd want to spot check
some of my data anyways,
something bad has happened.
A value of NA in R means that a
value is missing, and, more
generally, oftentimes functions
will return NA if
any of the observations
are missing.
If I took a look through our
data set, I'd find that there
are several observations
with missing NA values.
Here, I've checked how many
entries in the column low of
the stocks data set
are missing.
In many functions, such as min
and max, there's an optional
extra argument that is useful
for ignoring missing data, the
NA.RM argument, which I
will set to true in
the min and max functions.
Now when I re-run the code,
I get sensible results.
I'd want to look at the data
more carefully to see why some
observations are missing, but
I'll leave this as a topic for
another set of videos.
One final word--
even in this example, there are
other, better functions
that could have been used
to get the same
results much more quickly.
This would be important for
code that should be
implemented efficiently, and
I'll get to these functions in
the future.
However, for the beginning R
programmer, it's sometimes
easier and clearer to simply
implement a for loop.